seconde et va tout de suite consacrée au
cabinet de conseil le sénat vient de
faire une proposition de loi directement
issues des travaux sa commission
denquête objectif mieux encadrer le
recours par l'état ces experts privés
samia de chiens
leur commission d' enquête a révélé
l'ampleur du recours au cabinet de
conseil par l'état et ses opérateurs
plus d'un milliard d'euros en 2021 soit
deux fois plus qu'en 2018 les sénateurs
veulent encadrer le recours au cabinet
de conseil leur proposition de loi
transpartisane prévoit d'obliger le
gouvernement à publier chaque année la
liste de toutes les prestations de
conseil auquel il a recours depuis la
fin de nos travaux et de nos pouvoirs
banquette personne ne connaît la liste
de prestations de conseil en cours ce
qui est nouveau est déjà un problème
transparence repose désormais sur le
travail des journalistes qui saisissent
la commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs pour obtenir des
informations que l'administration refuse
souvent de leur donner plus de
transparence et de déontologie pour
éviter tout conflit d'intérêts le sénat
veut confier une mission de contrôle des
cabinets est la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et pour
plus de traçabilité tout document
élaboré directement ou indirectement
avec un cabinet de conseil devra en
faire les mentions ne souhaitons
également éviter toute confusion entre
les cabinets de conseil d'une part et
les fonctionnaires d'autre part un
consultant n'est pas un fonctionnaire il
nous semble utile de le rappeler au
gouvernement à titre d'exemple les
cabinets de conseil ne pourront plus ne
pourront plus utiliser le logo de
l'administration pour rédiger leur
livrables les sénateurs proposent aussi
la destruction systématique des données
confiées au cabinet de conseil sous le
contrôle de la cnil documente les 16
signataires issus de tous bords
politiques ont écrit à elisabeth bonne
pour lui demander de lancer l' examen de
leur proposition de loi des s'était
brûlé au parlement et je vous présente
tout de suite mes invités eliane assassi
on vient de vous voir dans dans ce
reportage
moon ont 7 vous n'êtes pas la seule mais
cette commission denquête et les travaux
pour mener à ces propositions des lois
vous êtes sénatrice communiste de
seine-saint-denis bienvenue à vous
bienvenue également à matthieu
courtecuisse
bon soit vous êtes friands du cabinet de
conseil sia partners et président de
syntec conseil qui est le syndicat des
professionnels de ce secteur quand un
calme et heureux de vous accueillir à
cette place porta journalistes à public
sénat musicalement et vous venez de
réaliser un documentaire sur ce thème
cabinet de conseil l'état sous influence
avec un point d'interrogation
ce film sera diffusé ce samedi 25 juin à
17h30 pour la première diffusion
matthieu croissandeau est toujours à mes
côtés est toujours éditorialiste
politique quelques chiffres et quelques
dates pour pour commencer sur les
travaux de cette commission denquête les
auditions commencent en novembre 29
novembre 2021 et se termine le 17 mars
40 audition 47 personnes entendues 7300
documents recueillis et analysés eliane
assassi vous avez présenté hier cette
proposition laquelle l'aboutissement du
travail de la commission denquête quel
est votre objectif
meilleur encadrement plus de
transparence je pense qu'on s'est fixé
quatre objectifs c'est la transparence
là vous l'avez dit c'est
je rajouterais danser danser objectif de
veiller à la bonne utilisation de
l'argent public bien évidemment la
question de la souveraineté qui est
posée la souveraineté d'autres d'autres
pays ont fait un tas d'objectifs qui
nous permette effectivement d'avoir une
meilleure lisibilité et une meilleure
visibilité de ce qu'est le recours à un
cabinet de conseil privé et de voir
effectivement si ce recours n'influence
pas les politiques les politiques
publiques je pense que c'est assez clair
nous avons beaucoup travaillé
le rapport a été adopté à l'unanimité de
la commission des membres de la
commission denquête cette proposition de
loi que nous avons déposé hier sera
signé par l'intégralité des
the ex membre de la commission denquête
donc nous avons un fourni un travail
sérieux un travail rigoureux un travail
qui a eu de l'écho un travail qui
conduit a investi l'espace public
beaucoup de gens nous ont parlé de ce2
ce2 ce rapport ces dernières ces
dernières semaines donc je trouve que
c'est un sujet d'intérêt public en fait
d'intérêt général est d'intérêt public
et on vend on va pouvoir voilà on va
rentrer dans les lieux après mais je
trouve que c'est un travail très comment
dire pédagogique aussi qu'il ya eu des
vertus pédagogiques pour le plus grand
nombre d'entre eux matthieu courtecuisse
vous avez participé évidemment vous avez
tué le
entendu par cette grille l enquête sur
le grill c'est le terme que vous
employez ce n'était pas si facile si ça
s'était très bien passé non mais c'est
juste pour savoir sur le peut-être le
constat est ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour dire que le recours au cabinet de
conseil par l'état nécessite plus de
transparence - c'est le premier mot qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est ce sentiment
en voyant les auditions les résultats la
commission denquête ou le documentaire
de de quentin qui avait quand même
beaucoup d'opacité
moi je pense que le mot d'opacité n'est
pas adapté aux constats parce que la
réalité c'est que d'abord à l'issue de
cette commission non on concert qui a
pas eu vraiment de révélations le seul
fait nouveau est que nous on connaît oti
de la profession c'est le nombre de
transferts entre les hauts
fonctionnaires et le secteur du conseil
c'est une donnée qu'on n'avait pas
connaissance on reconnaissait évidemment
des gens mais on savait pas exactement
quel était le volume concerné et je
rappelle que ces 15 mouvements cumulées
dans les deux sens par an donc ce n'est
pas quelque chose de majeur parce que
c'est -0 3% de l'ensemble des mouvements
public privé
voilà exactement donc c'est très limité
en réalité dont vous auriez pas ces
chiffres c'est ce que vous avez sur
l'opacité pourquoi vous dire que ce
n'est pas adapté non parce que en fait
d'abord la profession publie les
chiffres depuis plus de 20 ans fait donc
et les chiffres ont été confirmés même
si on a des débats sur le périmètre en
question parce qu'on n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord sur la nomenclature et des
comparatifs qu'on pourrait faire aussi
au niveau européen mais nous ces
chiffres on est mis à la disposition à
lorient on les a mis à disposition à
nouveau pour l'année 2020 terrain est
très peu de journalistes nous lisons
demandez donc au fait ces données là
elle existe alors elles sont pas au
niveau évidemment détail est bon de
commande par bon de commande ça c'est
évident mais aujourd'hui par contre les
chiffres macro tout le monde les a alors
je reste sur cette idée et quand un
jeune appuyé sur votre témoignage parce
que puisqu'on parle de
transparence il ya une audition qui est
vraiment intéressante à raconter celle
du ministre de la santé olivier véran
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se passe dans
les jours qui précèdent en fait en fait
c'est l'une des portes d'entrée du
documentaire est effectivement thomas et
puisque olivier ferrand et auditionné le
2 février mais que est la commission
d'enquêté constituée depuis le mois de
novembre et va demander le 10 décembre à
pouvoir accès à tous les documents
auxquels ont participé des cabinets de
conseil privé ou auquel ils ont eu accès
et ce qui va se passer c'est que la
veille de l'audition d'olivier ferrand
qui est donc le 2 février donc le 1er
février
très tard dans la soirée la fin à 19h30
les le sénat va voir un un mail avec un
50 gigas de données dans le mail en
pièce jointe ça représente 5000
documents et donc les administrateurs du
sénat et c'est ce qu'on raconte dans le
documentaire vont essayer de classer un
peu rapidement pour préparer l'audition
d'olivier ranquet le lendemain ils vont
se rendre compte qu aucun des documents
du ministère de la santé notamment les
documents sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire aucun et logoté ça qu'on
n'arrive pas à voir dans les documents
du ministère lesquels ont été fabriqués
entièrement par mckinsey lesquels ont
été fabriqués en partie par mckinsey j
mc kinsey parce que c'est un des
cabinets emblématique et c'est aussi
celui qui a eu plus d'une dizaine de
contraintes pour notamment gérer la
campagne de vaccination est donc lorsque
olivier ferrand il est auditionné vous
allez lui montrer des documents vous
allez demander tout simplement olivier
ferrand caisse café mckinsey sur le
document est ce qu il a participé un peu
est-ce qu'il a complètement écrit le
document et les sénateurs c'est là qu'il
parle d'opacité c'est qu'il n'arrive pas
à savoir ce qui a été fait par des
membres d'un d'une entreprise privée ou
pas des membres du cabinet ministériel
et pour eux c'est même juste qu'on peut
même pas savoir si le le document rendu
par l'entreprise privée est de bonne
qualité ces mêmes mots justes pour pour
savoir si leur île le livrable comme on
les appelle ces documents est de bonne
facture et ça c'est un problème pour eux
alors vous allez pouvoir répondre
là-dessus mais je voulais qu'elle quelle
conséquence vous en tirez dans la
proposition de loi par exemple
sur la transparence
le savoir qui fait quoi c'est justement
tout on nous demande ont effectivement
la publication
la liste des missions qui sont confiées
par notre administration à des cabinets
privés mais aussi la liste des bons
commandes puisqu'il faut on est quand
même là là là là la commande qu'elle est
la commande que dell à l'intitulé de la
mission quel est l'objectif qu'on veut
atteindre et le bon de commande y
afférents ça vous paraît quand même être
la moindre des choses et c'est ça que
nous appelons aussi la transparence
c'est à dire que ce soit connue par le
plus grand nombre alors matthieu
courtecuisse comment vous l'expliquez
assez choquant c'est est-ce que ça et
c'est un un procédé habituel au
harcèlement de fonctionnement de toute
organisation en fait qu'elles soient
publiques ou privées je prends un autre
exemple le rapport met en évidence le
bleu plus gros contrat me semble-t-il et
le contrat qui était confiée une société
française qui gère le parc des bons sur
ce qu'est un contrat de 80 90 millions
nommez moi donc c'est un très beau
contrat et donc il fait l'objet de
énormément de bons de commande en
réalité bon et je donne un exemple très
concret même si c'est pas mon entreprise
qui travaille dessus mais j'ai une idée
par un nouveau dispositif de fraude à la
plaque d'immatriculation qui se met en
place l'équipe s'en aperçoit d'accord
donc elle va demander en fait aux
prestataires de conseils de l'aider à
formaliser une réponse à ça d'accord
donc notamment vers spécifié le système
informatique qui va permettre de
détecter en articulant avec de la route
reconnaissance faciale de la
reconnaissance de la plaque
d'immatriculation
oui en fait c'est un travail collectif
parce que ce sont des gens qui
travaillent ensemble pendant 2 3 à 5 ans
en fait c'est des contrats très long et
ils sont sur un plateau projet et y
travaillent ensemble main dans la main
donc à la jambe c'est normal que le logo
d un savoir est ce que c'est le
fonctionnaire qui a fait ceci ou cela ou
est ce que c'est le consultant quand
c'est un contrat particulièrement long
c'est compliqué à établir la en l'espèce
c'est une réponse à la crise avec aussi
un sentiment d'urgence je pense que
l'ensemble des documents qui lui ont été
transmis c'est des choses qui sont
élaborées dans l'urgence donc en fait la
question c'est une question de
l'efficacité et c'est à dire qu'en fait
il faut pouvoir apporter des réponses
rapides à des dispositifs et après si on
publie bon de commande par bon de
commande évoquée par exemple si on donne
le nom commande qui est nouvelle fraude
à la plaque d'immatriculation ou nouveau
nouveau type de fraude fiscale
modification de l'algorithme parcours
sur des choses comme ça est ce que on
peut mettre en place une donnée une base
de données publique qui va
éventuellement servir à des fraudeurs
qui peut servir en termes d'outils
d'intelligence économique à des
puissances étrangères vous dites qu'il
faut un peu d'opacité pour cela c'est à
dire qu'en fait il faut au choix et
donner d'autres exemples on l'évoqué
juste avant vous avez parfois un audit
indépendant qu'il fait dans un
département alors là c'est encore plus
compliqué de l'évaluer parce que cet
ordinaire s'il doit être indépendant si
vous les mettez une note à la fin le
l'auditeur lui-même va se dire ben j
intègre le dispositif de la note et ça
va me contraintes dans mes
recommandations donc faire attention au
niveau de granularité qu'on va avoir
c'est pas pour être opaque c'est juste
pour être efficace et attentif à de
l'information qui pourraient circuler
dans des malles des mains mal
intentionnées
un élément après les premières auditions
devant votre commission denquête il ya
une réaction du gouvernement circulaient
on est le 15 janvier 2022 voilà ce
qu'elle nous propose cette circulaire
baisse de 15% des dépenses hors
informatique justification du recours à
un prestataire extérieur évaluation des
prestations paul interministériel
d'achat de prestations intellectuelles
évaluation des prestations prévention
des conflits d'intérêts et à ça si on
voit sens dit mais pourquoi il faut une
loi il faut aller plus loin non mais ce
que nous avons dit hier c'est que cette
circulaire est en fait un mur de papier
d'abord il faut rappeler le contexte
comment es tu arrivé circulaire c'est sa
circulaire a été connue le jour de
l'audition de madame amélie de
montchalin alors ministre de la
transformation public pour nous et il
était évident parce qu'il n'y a rien de
contraignant dans cette circulaire il
était évident que l'exécutif était pris
de panique devant l'ampleur des travaux
de la commission deux enquêtes et a
réagi en produisant cette circulaire qui
franchement
je les paie n'est pas contraignante ne
contacte donc nous préférons que des
éléments soient inscrits directement
dans la loi est une vertu légal alors
prenons appui effectivement sur cette
proposition de loi cette circulaire plus
personne n'en parle plus personne n'en
parle mathieu s'attend jeu parfois sur
rôle du parlement surtout en ce moment
on a quand même une splendide de
manifestations de ce que peut donner le
parlement à son meilleur dans une de ses
missions clés le contrôle de l'exécutif
on oublie c'est ça le parlement bavay
gueule avec des dessinateurs ça se
passait ici au sénat des sénateurs de
tous bords et qui ont mis sur le table
soit un sujet qui est devenu politique
qui est devenu politique occupé la
campagne présidentielle parce qu'ils
causent beaucoup de casse qui ont heurté
les français et l'aspect genji
financière qui n'a pas forcément été
compris par les français mais il ya des
sommes en jeu qui sans doute valent ce
qu'elles valent pour des prestations
qu'on peut comprendre que l'état ne
dispose pas forcément d'informaticiens
lapointe pour en faire un système
informatique quand je vous dépenser 500
mille euros pour la préparation d'un
colloque lord il ya quand même personne
dans cet état qui est par ailleurs
dénoncé comme pléthorique pour préparer
un colloque l'ania peut-être moins
besoin de compétences super technique ça
il ya les accusations d'opacité c'est
vrai que ça dieu sait qu'on est quand
même dans une société de la conspiration
en ce moment on se dit voilà il se passe
des choses on n'est pas au courant là
c'était la preuve par neuf et puis en
plus les allers-retours public-privé et
là c'est le côté ingérence du privé des
intérêts privés dans les intérêts de
l'état plus des puissances étrangères
qui pouvait être au courant enfin bref
ça alimenter tout un tout un vrai débat
et c'est vrai que ça nécessite une
régulation et quand on dit cette
circulaire pardon j'arrête là on se
demande pourquoi ce n'était pas le cas
plutôt bien qu'il n'y ait pas au moins
des présents
je pense que cette proposition de loi en
fait elle va rendre service aux cabinets
conseils parce qu'elle va clarifier le
sens
des missions qui sont les leurs et je
pense que c'est important c'est
important pour effectivement notre
administration etc mais c'est aussi
important alors là que vous le recevez
comme tel alors d'abord j'ai aussi le
point sur le mode de gabegie ou de
démence importante et c'est aussi
indiqué dans le rapport la france c'est
cinq fois moins que l'allemagne et
l'allemagne n'est pas réputé comme étant
à dans une logique de gabegie financière
non mais enfin rapporté non mais
rapportée à la masse salariale aurait
apporté à cette loi c'est là à l'arrêter
c'est votre fils votre apport qui le
montre donc en fait il s'appuie aussi un
peu sur nos chiffres mais mais mais
c'est quand même un rapport de 1,5 1,5
avec l'allemagne et je pourrais faire le
panégyrique avec l'ensemble des pays
européens sans parler des pays anglo
saxons donc la france dépense beaucoup
moins un gouvernement français dépensent
beaucoup moins un conseil que tous les
gouvernements équivalent dans les piles
de cd par rapport aux autres pour moi je
pense que quand on lit tout ça pourquoi
en fait c'est qu'aujourd'hui a eu des
marchés cadres qui ont été passées qui
donnait la flexibilité d'usagé et du
recours aux consultants c'est quoi il
veut pas c'est à dire en fait vous vous
faites un appel d'offres une fois tous
les x années et ensuite vous avez une
facilité par le jeu des bons de commande
avec des mécanismes qui vont avec et qui
permettent d'activer facilement et c'est
utile notamment lorsqu'il ya une crise
une urgence donc et ça je pense que
personne ne peut remettre en cause la
nécessité pour l'état face à une menace
subite de pouvoir répondre dans
l'urgence
simplement en fait ce qui est important
aussi c'est que c'est un coût de gestion
en fait le fait de faire passer des
appels d'offres temps quand vous avez
des appels d'offres qui qui sont pour
10000 20000 euros et c est que en fait
toute la procédure d'elle-même d'appel
d'offres que ce soit d'ailleurs du côté
de des fonctionnaires que des cabinets
très simplement si on calibre pas
correctement le dispositif il ya un
risque tout simplement décalé ne répond
plus d'accord ça c'est le don qu'il ya
moins de concurrence mais c'est pour ça
qu'il est laid
et les prix vont augmenter ça c'est
aussi une réalité de ce qui va se passer
c'est que plus ça sera compliqué de
passer un marché plus les prix augmenter
et j'ai donc on a un souci d'efficacité
globale donc je dis pas qu'il ya eu des
missions qui posait problème on ne rend
ma tâche complexe on régule facile parce
que avec par exemple si vous mettez en
place des comités qui vont parce que
dans la semaine dans la circulaire il ya
des comités en plus pour valider
l'engagement
mais dans le projet de loi je crois que
le soleil a disparu mais si j'ai donc là
ils n'ont la circulaire et à 500000 la
dent projet de loi il ya plus de seuil
il me sembla mais je suis pas sous notre
contrôle donc ça veut dire premier euro
dépensé il y aura un comité qui sera mis
en place pour valider l'intérêt de la
dépense
non mais sauf que ça veut dire que vous
allez réunir tout un tas de gens donc
évidemment il y aura moins de 2000 sont
bons on a
promis il nous reste du temps dans ce
débat mais j'aimerais qu'on regarde un
extrait assez emblématique de votre
documentaire quentin c'est ça il vous
l'avez évoqué à mathieu ça concerne le
cabinet mckinsey regarder
mckinsey géant mondial du conseil
présent dans 45 pays du monde certaines
prestations interroge les sénateurs vous
avez obtenu un contrat d'un montant de
496 1800 euros
pour je cite
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant d'enseignants vous pouvez
nous dire à quoi aboutit cette mission
control a été d'accompagner la dtp pour
organiser un séminaire qui était prévu
par le ministère en lien avec son
d'organisations internationales pour
réfléchir à quelles étaient les les
grandes tendances d'évolution de marcher
près de 500000 euros pour préparer une
réflexion pour un colloque qui n'a
jamais eu lieu voilà je crois que ça
peut interroger tout le monde même ceux
qui ne sont pas connaisseur des affaires
publiques quand un calme et pourquoi il
est on a un peu la réponse là mais
pourquoi il y en a ce point emblématique
cet extrait le lie son de mckinsey c'est
le 18 janvier c'est une audition qui va
être isolée sur les réseaux sociaux dont
les extraits vont être isolée sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui vont énormément
tourné l'extrait avec la question d
irena sassi va faire 8,6 millions de
vues
setc public sénat qui twitte salon pour
la chaîne on s'est rendu compte mais
c'est très intéressant sur c'est ce que
disait mathieu sur l'intérêt du public
pour pour ce dossier tout simplement
est-ce que avec avec tous les leviers
que qui sont en quête change tous les
contenus qu'on va poster nous pour
essayer de décrypter ce que commencent à
mettre à jour les à la commission tous
les contenus que va poster public sénat
vont être à chaque fois extrêmement
relayé à moindre et une interview que on
va faire des menaces à siffler 170000
vue et des choses comme ça et juste
après cet extrait c'est là que karim
tadjeddine est interrogé sur le fait
qu'ils payent les impôts ou non qu'il va
dire qu'il en paye est en fait la
commission denquête s'est rendu à bercy
je crois que vous êtes rendu deux fois à
bercy pour voir sur pièces et sur place
c'est à dire c'est une des prérogatives
des commissions d'enquêté elles peuvent
elles se rendent dans les ministères on
ne peut pas leur interdire l'accès à des
documents elles peuvent lever le secret
fiscal le seul secret qui leur reste
c'est le secret défense mais donc là ils
ont pu regarder ce qu'avait fait
mckinsey ces dix dernières années et les
sénateurs se rendre compte que et bien
effectivement mais qui ne s'est déclarée
des résultats négatifs par un système
d'optimisation fiscal avec les états
unis et que donc le groupe ne ne payent
pas d'impôts sur les bénéfices et donc
là il ya dès maintenant des des
poursuites judiciaires qui sont qui sont
enclenchées donc la voilà la commission
d' enquête
prend encore un nouveau tour puisque la
justice va s'en mêler puisque une
enquête préliminaire qui était ouverte
mais on va on voit que dans le temps et
bien et bien la polémique elle monte
elle rattrape la campagne électorale
puisque même les matons va devoir
répondre alors justement on a cet
extrait de la réponse d'emmanuel macro
on est le 27 mars 2022 il est sur france
3 1 il n'y a aucun contrat qui est passé
dans la république sans qu'ils
respectent la règle des marchés publics
mise en concurrence transparence
responsabilité de celles et ceux qui
signent donc tout est clair là dessus de
ma maison que oui sinon c'est du pénal
d'accord et donc que quiconque a la
preuve qu'il ya une manipulation met le
contrat en cause au pénal alors sur un
cycle de l'arctique donc de non-paiement
pardon de l'impôt se résoudre à la fois
très clair parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils avaient combine c'est faux il ya
des règles d'un marché public la france
est un pays de droit s'il ya des preuves
de manipulation que sai au pénal mathieu
ce dossier il n'est pas anodin non plus
pour emmanuel macron ça le ramène aussi
une histoire à son 10 ans il se trouve
que parmi ses collaborateurs ses plus
proches collaborateurs c'est mormons
comment le diseur 2017 il eût d'aider
des personnes qui ont travaillé pour des
cabinets de conseil il se trouve que lui
en plus avec la vocation d'incarner la
start-up nacion évidemment prêter le
flanc à toutes ces accusations de
mélange des genres public privé après il
faut évidemment pas généraliser et pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain mais je
reviens juste au delà de la firme
mckinsey pour moi qui suis un béotien
dans cette affaire cinq cent mille euros
pour préparer un séminaire sur
l'évolution du métier d'enseignant dans
un pays où on compte un million de
professeurs l'administration de
l'éducation nationale à tous les
services possibles et imaginables pour
scruter ce que commande le métier
d'enseignant évolué depuis des années
c'est sûr que pour le pékin moyen c'est
incompréhensible qu'on ait confié sa un
cabinet extérieur alors on peut
peut-être dire ou alors c'est dire et
c'est ça ou sablé c'est aussi une partie
le public voilà c'est à dire les
fonctionnaires sont nuls ça veut dire
nous qui avions une tradition de haute
fonction publique et je reviens ce que
vous dites et sur la comparaison avec
les pays étrangers dans les pays
étrangers il ya beaucoup de gens qui
font des passerelles public-privé 5 y
sont acceptés normalisée nous on avait
quand même addition de haute fonction
publique et les grands corps si les gens
qui vont donner à paul juste après
simplement dans le trou bien évidemment
ça a froissé des beaucoup de gens
parlent l'ampleur et puis le fait que
cette mission ne savais pas trop ce à
quoi l année où elle avait atterri mais
je crois qu'il ya eu une rencontre aussi
une rencontre parce qu'il ya le texte et
le contexte comme je dis souvent
rencontre avec à ce moment là et c'était
pas voulu de notre part une mobilisation
du monde enseignant donc ça les a
profondément heurté et puis de façon
plus générale la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui était déjà beaucoup présente
dans le débat public matthieu
courtecuisse eux il ya cet exemple qui a
choqué tout le monde mais si on essaye
de généraliser un petit peu que que dit
le client et à face à une telle étude
est ce qu'ils payent quand même moi
c'est vraiment une question de base que
je me pose que le dc si on a une étude
qui sert pas à grand chose est ce qu'on
paye quand même quoi c'est déjà les
consultants serait de vos coeurs vocable
adnot tome sur des missions longues etc
enfin si ça se passe pas très bien tout
de suite le client l'acheteur peut
révoquer le consultant il ya des leviers
juridiques pour le faire après parfois
c'est sur des accords sur des dépenses
engagées etc mais ça peut tout à fait se
faire donc là en l'espèce si on
considère que ce rapport avait pas lieu
d'être il avait tout à fait la
possibilité juridique de dire que ce
rapport à la mission aurait pu être
arrêté vous savez l'arrivée des cas de
force majeure il ne semble pas qu'il y
avait là le colloque avait pas pu avoir
lieu et c'est donc avait des leviers
juridiques qui n'ont pas été activés par
l'acheteur dans le cas d'espèce payer
pour ça oui il aurait pu le faire ne
l'ont pas fait mention sur l'acheteur
c'est précisément le ministère oui oui
tout à fait c'est ça je dirais que le
ministère aurait pu
c'est aurait pu activer des et l'a pas
fait mais plus généralement est ce que
l'état est satisfait oui il ya des
retours entre entre donneurs d'ordres et
justement c'est un des apports du
rapport c'est qu'il ya eu des
habitations qui sont eux qui ont été
faites et globalement trois quarts des
milliers d'émissions qui sont réalisés
sont jugées satisfaisantes ou très
satisfaisante ok pas mais on a pressé
les personnes qui sont impliquées
elle-même dans le dans le rap dans
l'exécution de la mission donc
l'évaluation est toujours donnée par
celui qui en proximité avec avec
l'évaluation mais globalement ça marche
bien et je dirais que soient publics ou
privés d'ailleurs le développement du
secteur du conseil en france et dans
tous les pays attestent une certaine
qualité puisque en fait on se développe
là on fait 10 % de croissance l'année
dernière encore 10% cette année donc en
fait ça veut dire qu'on va dire les
entreprises privées elles n'achètent pas
des prestations conseil par plaisir
elles le font parce qu'elles considèrent
que ça leur est utile et l'a donc le le
score qui avait été obtenue est plutôt
pas mal en fait donc ya pas de questions
alors je dis pas qu'il ya pas des
missions qui peuvent poser problème mais
globalement il ya un accord de
satisfaction générale oui et bien là ça
si ce n'est pas l'existence des cabinets
de conseils que vous remettez en cause
dit même le recours
un lecteur par les pouvoirs publics cc
c'est quoi c'est peut-être leur
influence sur les politiques ça devient
aussi cette fameuse question de la
transparence qui reste posée je pense
que les débats parlementaires avec la
proposition de loi vous pour le coup
essayer d'éclairer ce ce sujet mais oui
on sait
attendu il y à des connivences on le
sait les gens se connaissent entre des
membres de l'exécutif
voire même au plus haut niveau et des
membres de cabinets conseils qu'il y ait
une certaine influence sur les choix on
sait très bien que les cabinets des
cabinets conseils je vais dire comme ça
propose différents scénarii
en réponse à la commande qui leur a été
fait est qu'ils orientent de toute façon
le choix qui doit être donc à la
question est est-ce une influence vous
vous répondez oui oui je réponds qu'est
ce que vous répondez par exemple le plus
gros contrat dont on parlait tout à
l'heure sur les registres des parcs de
radars automatiques enfin est-ce que
c'est des consultants qui ont dit qu'il
fallait déployer départ des radars et
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ça a une influence
un des gros dossiers qui a eu lieu sur
eden année c'est le déploiement du
prélèvement à la source est ce qu'on
imagine que c'est des consultants qui
ont dit qu'il fallait faire du
prélèvement à la source dans la capacité
de réponse à la crise qu'a dit oui sur
le mécanisme le fait que les
prélèvements elle suspecte honnêtement
je pense pas qu'ils aient des
consultants qui est dit voilà
franchement ça m'étonnerait les mots
raison vous nous vous vous dites le
politique garde la main en cas il semble
qu'on est toujours au service des
décideurs et on n'a pas de problème
d'ailleurs ce que ce soit formalisée en
qu'en plus nous ça correspond à la
à la chose donc mais à un moment donné
évidemment qu'on aboutit à une
recommandation avec plusieurs scénarios
bon le décideur qui décide au travers de
façon de présenter peut évidemment voir
une influence contestées vous savez très
bien que par exemple s'agissant du
conseil de défense les parlementaires
que nous sommes n'étions pas du tout au
courant de ce qui ce qui était membre de
ce conseil de défense et ce qui se
disait dans ce conseil de défense du
conseil de défense sanitaire
par contre on a découvert que le fameux
mackinsey produisait des documents
destinés
au conseil de défense sanitaire vous
montrer c'est le document que je montre
lors de l'audition de monsieur vers on
pourrait citer coûts produisent et parce
que l'accord conduisait mais bon excusez
moi mais nous nous sommes les
parlementaires nous n'étions même pas au
courant de ces missions et nous n'étions
pas au courant de ce qui se tramait au
sein du conseil de défense sanitaire
c'est quand même un problème
démocratique me semble-t-il c'est que d
un cabinet extérieur privé puisse
intervenir sur des choix quand même
éminemment stratégique allez un mot de
réponse
c'est ultra minoritaire dans l'instant
des démissions qui sont qui sont
réalisés ces premiers points le deuxième
point c'est qu'ils n'ont à ma
connaissance pas participer aux
délibérations c'est à dire que vous
faites il produisait au co produisent et
des rapports qui étaient soumis aux
membres du conseil de défense et c'était
le conseil de défense souverain qui
décidez derrière et je dirai demain je
parlais de transparence ne l'avons pas
ne le saviez pas tout simplement annoncé
par jean babin pourquoi je crois pas
qu'il y avait de se créer sur le fait
qu'il y avait des cabinets de conseil
qui a intervenu vous pouvez regarder
même il ya eu des pleins de choses qui
avaient circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
déjà à l'époque parce que dans les
slides fallait les présentations qui
était monté par edouard philippe il y
avait le drapeau italien au néerlandais
qui avait été mis à l'envers est tout le
monde rigolait sur les réseaux sociaux
disons que c'était mckinsey qui les
effets dopants je veux dire mais ce qui
est important c'est que demain imaginons
de moyenne attaque de cyber sécurité
majeur sur le pays on va pas se demander
qui fait quoi essayer de faire en sorte
qu'on ait une réponse efficace et c'est
et c'est ça qui est quand même et là on
est obligé de faire appel
dans l'administration des gens qui sont
saines
je pense que non sur certaines
techniques d'accueil de cybersécurité je
pense qu'à des cabinets qui sont non
mais en l'occurrence là sur la crise
sanitaire ben je pense que par exemple
sur l' on avait évoqué lors de mon
audition sur la logistique du grand
froid il ya l'état a fait appel à un
cabinet qui n'avaient jamais travaillé
pour l'état qui spécialisée dans le
circuit du grand froid sur les sur les
médicaments et il fallait absolument on
n'avait jamais fait ça au niveau de
l'état et donc il fallait une expertise
qui permettait trait sur la liste il
allait je reprends la main une minute
parce que ça peut sembler anecdotique
mais c'est en fait symbolique j'appelle
jérémy semaine à nous rejoindre dans la
proposition de loi jérémy on trouve un
article qui vise à supprimer les
anglicismes dans dans ses rapports et
dans les cabinets conseils oui cet
article c'est l'article 7 de la
proposition de loi qui imposerait aux
consultants d'employés la langue
française dans leurs échanges avec
l'administration et la rédaction de
leurs documents il nous pourrait
utiliser une expression ni termes
étrangers lorsqu'il existe une
expression un terme français de même
sens au besoin les documents des
consultants pourrait être traduit dans
une autre langue mais en complément de
la version française donc par exemple au
lieu de benchmark il faudrait donc dire
comparaison à la place de paper board
tableau de seuils détachable actions
simples résultats rapides au lieu de
quick win on peut en faire un autre est
ce que vous savez thomas ce que c'est un
consultant on the beach pas du tout et
bien c'est un consultant entre deux
missions voilà c'est ce qu'il faudrait
dire c'est amusant parce qu'on voit que
la langue anglaise ou américaine est
quand même très efficace et beaucoup
moins de yakubu beaucoup moins de mots
pour dire là pour dire la même chose
bref pourquoi s'attaquer à ce jargon des
cabinets de conseil et bien dans leur
rapport les sénateurs dénoncent l'emploi
de ce terme technique qui participent
selon eux à l'opacité dont on parlait
d'un certain nombre de missions et donne
en fait une forme de supériorité au
consultant sur l'administration et selon
plusieurs études de cas qui figurent
dans le rapport des fonctionnaires se
disent infantiliser par les concepts
anglophone où les jeux de rôles très
utilisé par les cabinets de conseil
autrement dit c'est un c'est une
critique d'un rapport de force et qui
est partagé par l'écrivain nicolas
mathieu qui figure dans le documentaire
de quentin calmer et qui dans son
dernier roman connaît ma race est
intéressé justement au monde des
cabinets de conseil et alors langage je
vous propose de l'écouter comme tous les
langages faussement experts c'est assez
ronflants
c'est aussi assez excluant c'est à dire
que si on ne domine pas si on ne
maîtrise pas ce vocabulaire on ne
comprend pas ce qui s'y joue et puis ça
impose aussi une manière de penser c'est
un certain pouvoir en soit cette langue
et une fois que l vous passé au travers
une fois que vous la parlotte repassez
vous là par les pardons couramment il ya
des choses qui ne vous sont plus
autorisés il ya des choses que vous ne
pouvez plus penser c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne un langage expert alors un
langage start-up nationale a compris
dans le viseur de cette proposition de
loi mais qui existe aussi on a cherché
dans les rapports du sénat par exemple
dans le rapport d'information refonder
l'écosystème français et européen de
l'innovation en santé du 23 juin 2021 un
peu au hasard y en a d'autres on trouve
des anglicismes des propositions qui
reprenne les termes benchmark aux reason
gaming ou encore fast track donc le
sénat peut peut-être aussi nettoyer ses
rapports tu vas vite merci vivre ça vous
acceptez s'est pas seulement je le
disais c'est pas seulement symbolique
non mais c'est ce que disait il pas là
matière à des questions de prise de
pouvoir même vous ressentez comme tel
oui oui c'est simplement le langage de
langage d'un secteur à les deux les deux
je vais vous faire un aveu je je je
présente des émissions sur une chaîne et
cauet chute quand même frappé par ce
parent ça à quoi sert que c'est parfois
on se donne un petit côté cool en
employant des anglicismes ou alors
ou alors on on utilise des termes
anglais pour donner son titre on est on
est si haut etc etc voyez ce que je veux
dire non mais d'abord je crois pas que
ce soit lié au québec conseille c'est le
vocabulaire managériale d'ensemble et
puis le deuxième fois moi je peux vous
dire on travaille beaucoup au québec
j'ai plus de 100 personnes au québec et
on a appris à tout traduire en français
par un peu le mot de classer un faux
nuage est possible ça vous intéresse et
donc en fait je suis prêt je suis
s'il te ra
j'adore regarder un autre excès de votre
documentaire sur la doctrine de
gouvernement y avait-il un tacle dur une
doctrine du gouvernement en matière de
recours au cabinet regarder les
sénateurs interroge une personne clé
extrêmement discrète
la secrétaire général du gouvernement
claire landais est inconnu du grand
public et pourtant son rôle est crucial
pour coordonner l'exécutif et qui est
une administration qui soit chargée de
contrôler cette volumétrie de considérer
que est ce que justement c'est à bon
escient ou pas ça ça n'est pas le cas
pour l'ensemble des de ses prestations
elle nous confiance que nous avions déjà
plus ou moins entendu avec d'autres
grands taux fonctionnaires de l'état à
savoir qui a aucune vision centralisée
de la consommation de production de
cabinet de conseil elle va même nous
dire tout de suite après que ya pas de
doctrine et qu'elles doutent qu'une
doctrine soit même possible ou utile
quand inquiet cette au fonctionnaire
clerlande est donc secrétaire général du
gouvernement elle est très peu connu du
grand public c'est quand même elle est à
la tête d'une équipe de 110 personnes
qui en charge de coordonner l'action du
gouvernement qui est notamment là pour
faire une aide juridique sur l'écriture
des projets de loi du gouvernement donc
les sénateurs ils l'interrogent à cette
eau dans les auditions le 5 janvier il
pense avoir en face d'eux une personne
et qui va leur donner la doctrine de
comment est-ce qu'on recourt au cabinet
de conseil qu est-ce qui surveille qui
chapeaute tout ça est en fait dû se
rendre compte que cette personne là va
leur faire un aveu c'est cet aveu qu'on
entend et il y en a pas quoi voilà ces
cas où il ya aucune n'y a aucune
doctrine ya aucune tour de contrôle et
même elle dit que pour elle c'est pas
faisable que ce serait l utilise un
terme et que ce serait très compliqué de
mettre en place pour le gouvernement est
alors que cette déclaration ensuite
lorsque les sénateurs vont la mettre à
côté celle des ministres notamment celle
d'amélie de montchalin en charge de la
fonction publique qui elle va leur dire
si si tout va bien il ya une doctrine et
d'ailleurs on vient de la mettre à jour
avec la fameuse circulaire
circulez ya rien à voir eh bien les
sénateurs viennent de faire une
démonstration via deux auditions que
l'aïe avait il ya tus juste pour le
téléspectateur c'est le plus aux rouages
de l'état le gg c'est oui c'est le cas
après yaya l'elysée on dit secrétaire
général de l'elysée souhaite encore au
secrétaire jessica m'a déplu le sont
plus
donc l'objectif de votre loi s'est créé
une autre en quelque sorte
d'abord de créer des gardes des airs de
fouet puis effectivement d'essayer de
travailler de proposer une doctrine
visant à l'encadrement du recours à ces
cabinets conseils voilà c'est pas je le
répète cette proposition de loi n'a pas
vocation à tuer les cabinets conseils on
a bien compris mathieu aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'il faut une doctrine il ya déjà
une doctrine en fait elle est d'ailleurs
régis plus tôt par les marchés publics
européens parce qu'en réalité tous les
marchés sur lesquels on postule sont
régis par ça et ça c'est un point
d'attention notamment par rapport au
projet de loi c'est qu'il soit conforme
au droit européen et notamment parce
qu'il faudrait pas qu'on se retrouve
dans une situation pour faire simple
pour n'importe quel marché aujourd'hui
de conseil vous pouvez postuler que vous
soyez un cabinet français avec un
établissement un établissement stable en
france vous pouvez être un cabinet
belges ou allemands et il faudrait pas
que les contraintes qui s'applique aux
cabinets français soient supérieurs à
ceux qui s'appliquent au cabinet
d'autres pays européens sur
interprétation de la norme non c'est pas
ça c'est que par exemple la il est
indiqué dans le projet de loi qui aura
des déclarations d'intérêt à faire ou un
référentiel en 6 pour la sécurité or à
ma connaissance et pour la haute
autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique et pour lentilles non pas des
pouvoirs de son coup
ou de d'audit ou d'instruction sur les
personnes qui ne sont pas sur le
territoire enfin le territoire français
donc ça voudrait dire que concrètement
si il ya deux cabinets qui postule un
cabinet 100% français un cabinet
étranger qui postulent bien il sera pas
soumis aux mêmes réglementations donc il
faut faire attention donc ça c'est un
travail qu'on va essayer de faire
maintenant ensemble pour essayer de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient pas déjà une
distorsion de concurrence et que ça va
aboutir à quelque chose qui soit calibré
et responsable cette proposition de loi
qu'est ce qu'elle devient qu'est ce qui
va se passer maintenant alors cette
proposition de loi nous avons écrit à
madame la première ministre la semaine
dernière pour lui demander d'inscrire en
procédure accélérée ce texte afin de
mettre ce texte à l'ordre du jour 2 du
gouvernement au mois de juillet en
procédure accélérée au mois de juillet
pau l'heure nous n'avons pas de réponse
si tel n'est pas le cas je ne pense pas
qu'elle puisse dire non mais si tel
n'est pas le cas de toute façon nous
déposerons en séance publique cette
proposition de loi dans le cadre d'une
semaine sénatoriales et elle sera de
toute façon débattu et ce sera sans
doute à l'automne merci elle beaucoup
d'avoir participé tout ça ce à ce débat
cabinet de conseil l'état sous influence
c'est donc votre documentaire quentin
avoir ce samedi 25 17h30 première
diffusion sur public sénat